peu
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
some tôt pour le dire ça qd m'attendait
je m'attendais pas du tout ces lasers
situation les pénibles je suis pas très
courageux l'occasion je te dis c'est
qu'ils veulent peur et bien autant pour
moi que pour toi quand je t'en prie tête
occupe plus de ce qui me paraît bien
pour moi je suis assez grande
surtout à ces jeunes pourra faire ta vie
aujourd'hui sans difficulté alors
qu'elle s'y l'arc arc
alors que c'est la vie qui m'a refait tu
es tu le sait mieux que personne
mais tu t'en fou maintenant ce qui
compte pour toi c'est la nouvelle cuvée
ya cinq ans qui mène en bateau
voilà voilà tout ce que je voulais
éviter mais toi oh bah moi un beau petit
jérôme qui met à la porte
en fait tu veux prix gentiment de ne pas
remettre les pieds chez toi ça revient
exactement même nom c'est une séparation
provisoire tout à fait normal à mon avis
il faut tenir compte de la situation non
d'accord
je me retire
j'ai fait mon temps
mais tu me regrettera au voc est sûre
elle est jeune elle est belle serment au
petit tu me dégoûtes tiens
auteur de le prendre comme ça j'ai
beaucoup d'affection pour toi quoi de
l'infection quelle affection
mais qu'est ce que tu t'imagines que je
me consoler avec de l'affection sa louve
[Musique]
ça tourne mieux pour le frère que pour
la soeur on irait pourtant ça doit être
encore une bonne personne rencontrée
dans une grande villa prend soin de
l'espionner il y aura bien jouer la
politesse du bouchon de la bouteille
qu'envoyer des bâtiments faire travail
chez soi n'est pas prêt de l'argent par
ici là françoise méfie toi monsieur
jérôme nous regarde
cauchon mais tu demandes à dégouliner
plein la moquette
c'est pas toi qui fais nettoyage mais
que je t'attrape tu perd rien pour
attendre
et puis tu pourrais pas dire à sylvie de
venir chercher son goûter non
bon j'en ai marre de celui-là mais leur
marc marc marc platt oies les enfants
quand on ne les a pas tu là je te prends
entendu arriver quand je suis dans ma
lessive il s'est imaginé la v9 visitons
mais tu as pleuré toi alors c'est jérôme
oui tout est fini allons l on ma grande
faune une fille comme toi tu vas pas de
faire du chagrin pour un giro tu
comprends aussi si j'avais eu des
enfants et puis ne serait pas arrivé et
oui mais qu'est ce que tu veux avoir des
enfants avec un homme qui me tais pousse
pas c'est plus compliqué que ça alors si
c'est compliqué on va tendre ton frère
il va revenir de l'avion bientôt il sera
mieux de console et comment puis qui va
nous rester à dîner un jour ou deux
mêmes enfin cette chante je ne sais pas
te le demander mais j'avais tellement
gros sur le coeur
j'ai peur de faire une bêtise bon je
voudrais bien voir ça allait entre et
fais pas trop attention aux ménages j'ai
eu six personnes à dîner hier et de
hollandais hamidi qui sont venus
déjeuner ils ont acheté tout un lot au
moins 50 hectares à l'est pas lui et tu
fais des mots lucia je n'ai donc
déjeuner à la maison
cécile gallez oui oui faudrait vous
aider
ils ont bu de la bière la bière à trois
kilomètres de saint-émilion et en plus
ils avaient l'air d'approuver pas bonne
les litres viendra va tout nouveau tout
beau
vas-tu payé pour savoir que c'est pas
demain la veille des noces elle qu'un
garçon comme lui ça dégoûtera bienne
s'est amélioré et avant longtemps
[Musique]
et
dérangés par yves était là
moi j'arrive à un jour tu veux au
syndicat viticole mais j'avais quelque
chose de très important je tiens voilà
tout est clair du côté de françoise
j'espère que vous l'avez pas blessé non
évidemment ça n'a pas été aussi fair
play quand olivier vous mais ça aurait
pu être tellement pire est ce que vous
savez ça m'aurait caché beaucoup de
choses je sais mon petit jeu c'est parce
que vous êtes quelqu'un de très pur et
de très exigeant et si si vous m'avez
donné l'exemple parce que vous êtes
aussi quelqu'un de très propre je veux
arrêter qu'on me demande est dur avec
mes phrases bon enfin voilà tout est en
ordre
je pense que nous pourrions nous marier
vers la mi-décembre chinois ne pouvaient
pas comprendre parce que tout ce que
j'éprouve en votre compagnie depuis deux
mois le
je bafouille un peu sur votre
délicatesse pour me dire que vous mmes
accepté d'être que je suis pour moi
c'est merveilleux mais s'il ne tenait
qu'à moi tout est très vite mais vous
savez il faut compter avec les gens avec
le qu'en-dira-t-on
ma mère studio
c'est d'abord mois et à refuser le
mariage avec jérôme
expérience avec charges comprend divorce
après onze ans de mariage
insuffisant suffisant suffisant
aujourd'hui du temps dans les doigts je
n'ai pas dit mon dernier mot
à lévis et non plus j'espère oui
qu'est-ce qu'il attend pour rentrer
celui-là on jérôme ne l'épousera pas
c'est pas possible c'est pas possible
tout les sépare l'âge l'argent les idées
même les idées politiques
oui ça ça changera vu tout si je ne sais
pas ce que va gagner une espèce de sous
professeur d'anglais dans un lycée de
province
mais la patronne du château le bugue
excuse moi ça va être à gauche droite
rapide les idées politiques et
s'ennuiera avec elle qu'est ce que tu
veux qu'ils se disent tu serais pas ma
soeur je me dirai quelle gourde ya tout
de même pas que la conversation non
allez françoise voit la situation telle
qu'elle est sont les meubles vous étiez
des amants rester au moins d 1 des amis
tu as aussi alors parce que c'est
exactement ce qui m'a proposé figure-toi
l'affection
je leur ai dit fille j'aurais dû le
faire écoute françoise à part marié les
enfants tués ce que j'ai de plus cher au
monde
je te préviens pas de conneries avec
jérôme je peux pas me le permettre
si tu vas trop loin je serai dans son
corps à tous les coups
non mais vous vous rendez compte on
pyjama tout neuf ils étaient solides sa
soeur en tirant crack est encore
philippe et oui c'est encore fut c'est
françoise à une idée merveilleuse elle
va m'aider dans ma comptabilité
alors ça c'est pas bête mais c'est vrai
des comptes ton mari qui l'aimé bien
ah si je pouvais moi mais je suis trop
bête
et puis ça ne changera les idées
j'ai dit ça comme ça mais c'est vrai si
tu pouvais jeter un coup d'oeil sur ma
comptabilité tu comprendrais pourquoi je
ne veux pas de vagues avec jérôme
[Musique]
écoute g20 en avance sur tous ces
guignols la 20 ans d' avance
monsieur olivier ce alors on vous attend
avec demain oui je suis à faire votre
choix
je descends vous annonciez à madame est
donné si olivier que je suis content le
monde
comme vous avez maigri moi j'ai maigri
oui non modifié aucune bonne surprise
je suis dans mes confitures tu vois j'ai
même pas pris le temps d'ôter le tablier
tel est en bonne forme en pleine forme
en pleine forme si c'est à mon art enfin
et les vendant alors moi tu sais comment
je suis comme les raisins c'est mon
meilleur moment
non non paupiettes c'est pour la cuisine
du cognac california que j'ai ramené
pour mon oncle il est au petit coteau
avec félix on va aller le prévenir
il va faire qu'un bon du moins tu as
mauvaise mine
moi j'aime résumé mais oui on va le
préparer un bon café thiloise être
fatigué à mourir pas du tout ma vie j'ai
pu prendre l'avion hier j'ai dormi à
l'hôtel tu parfaitement bien et c'était
mairie alors raconté dans son jeu j'ai
été formidablement version du moins
incroyable
ah non pas après ce que toi dans trois
mois et doyen tu es parti mais non ce
même 20 minutes c'est bien simple je
suis parti juste après la floraison de
lys blancs
d'ailleurs c'était noter la gare olivier
cent jours après la floraison des lys
c'est l'ouverture des vendanges te
laisse pas prendre loin du pays oui
murray bien gardé encore mais voilà je
suis là dilou où elle
il hèle un peu tout c'est dès l'instant
qu'on leur parle de nos vins on a un
charme terrible maintenant c'est
complètement dingue tu sais qu'un hacker
de vue bourgogne ou de vieux bordeaux en
vitrine dans la pièce principale de
l'appartement mais non et des bouteilles
à 100 $ et plus
le shass urgemment derrière moi mais le
chantage l'air conditionné la lumière
des bouteilles des contraintes ou 40 ans
en six mois c'est de la flotte alors
jusqu'à des bouteilles de l'année de la
comète l'autre 1900 je les ai vus tu
sais je ne peux pas te promettre le même
mettant tour ça s'arrose ça allait bien
je crois que c'est le bon moment pour
traquer sur place celui-là tu le connais
c'est un peu jeune
mais tu sais
ça sera un millésime du contenu
voilà qui serait aimable ou alors
tu vois ça m'a fait plaisir ce que tu as
dit tout à l'heure tu fais quand je
plaisantais il ou elle est la façon dont
tu as répondu vous avez l'air d'aller
bien très bien parfait guerric on
tremble j'aime rêver en être tout à fait
sûr parce que tu vois ces trois là c'est
spécial entrées viandes fromages par une
cérémonie des doutes sérieux
j'aurais voulu être le patient des
romans provoquer c'est koné griots du
syndicat viticole il plaisanté sur la
différence d'âge entre yvette et moi tu
pars me donner une explication
mais si il y à dire entre autres oublier
qu'il l'a fauché alors son neveu
holliger c'est faux
oui je sais mais attend olivier qui
pourrait être son fils et ça c'est vrai
c'est pour ça que j'ai voulu qu'on parle
à peu les deux
tu m'as pas dit la date le mois prochain
no 22 ça me l'a juste le temps pour
monter hier c'est vraiment prometteur il
sera presque aussi bon que 70
même au grand champ bien dans quatre
jours on aura tous les étudiants là
dedans à remplir les comportes jusqu'à
craintes et dans le merlot du goût là
bas oxylane merlot toujours là pour
écuries
bien justement je vais jeter un coup
d'oeil des fois quand on s'y prend assez
tôt ça limite les dégâts
j'y vais j'ai su que tu venais d'entrer
je serai pas ses devoirs dans la journée
comme ça on sera plutôt en fait je te
dois des félicitations
je te remercie
tu me diras pour le cadeau je sais bien
que j'ai besoin de rien c'est jamais le
besoin qui justifie le 4 bon je te dirai
si je vois quelque chose mais tu sais ça
me fera plaisir de toute façon
je vais voir au château il paraît qu'il
ya déjà des vendangeurs ce soir au
revoir
[Musique]
à waterloo
d'abord
m
est ce qu'il peut
[Musique]
il demandait comment ça va mal les mâles
et qu'on plutôt moi ils font que leur
boulot qui moi tu sais les machines
c'est dans ma ligne eh bien j'ai loué
une machine à vendanger la plus moderne
première nouvelle tu ne l'as jamais
parlé et bien non quand on veut être le
premier sur un coup on n'en parle pas ou
alors on se fait griller d'autant plus
cher que je n'en veux plus j'ai déjà
versé 40 % tiens regarde dans les
investissements expérimentaux ah je vois
oui comme engrais 34 c'est ça la la la
la
et alors si ces économies 50 personnes
pendant trois semaines c'est tout à fait
raisonnable
seulement voilà je renonce et les 40 %
de réservations coûte sûrement ce
tournant c'est obligatoire c'est
obligatoire et c'est fait j'aurais
téléphoné ont traité de tous les noms
que j'ai été gâtée là dessus
c'est une ma faute d'ailleurs je m'en
prends toujours à pierre à paul tu te
souviens de ce que me disait maman tu
fais trop le glorieux m'ont lu ça coûte
je me voyais déjà sur cette machine à
trois mètres au dessus de tous ces
connards
c'est pas au 3 m mais c'est leur aurait
tout de même c'est lever le nez tu ne
diras tu déjà l'avion l'avion c'est
mieux mais c'est pas pareil tu perds les
expressions tu comprends sur les visages
la jalousie glorieux où jal avait raison
et ça marche
ces machines les chiffres étaient bons
trop trop bons trucs et ben non alors
alors je viens de recevoir un rapport
technique détaillée complet erreur
erreur on m'avait communiqué klich
charente le var l'hérault enfin
département à viña gobelet à buisson ben
c'était beau mais chez nous mais kevin
palissé la régie là sur toute la ligne
catastrophe tu me vois m'expliquer avec
le jérôme il milite chidren public or
mon époque j'étais fait pour les
colonies la conquête les milliers
d'hectares
tu me diras les colonies c'est du passé
la machine c'est de l'avenir hold'em
avec ton frère 1 en tout cas maintenant
il va falloir tu me dégoûtes une équipe
de vendangeurs
mais la veille de l'ouverture j'ai guère
le choix des moyens
jérôme
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
e
[Musique]
enfin un ami on pouvait pas prévoir ça
avec lui il faut tout prévoir un moyen
flexible un moment qu'on va pouvoir
prendre une décision l'exil qu'est ce
qui se passe donc aux lésés qui ne sont
pas parties un record justement chez
vous qu'on attendait monsieur giraud
mais il ya un petit ennui ferait qu'on
envoie au moins 20 à 30 jeunes gens chez
lucien lesponne on commence à séduire
les palais il n'a pas prévu son compte
c'est à dire sans compter zéro il avait
choisi jean une machine qui allait venir
en place et tout mais qu'elle ne vient
plus du coup il faut sans monde
qu'est ce que ça veut dire
tammy sutton n'avons jamais il nous faut
dans la pagaille bon dieu 2 j'étais sûr
que ça se passerait estampes et il me
suit à vendanger c'est capable sans
réussit rien nulle part c'est
imagineront fellering comment fait de la
luzerne la violer ce qu'on avait raison
quand il disait silva mêmes leurs
enseignants ne peut rien faire
ils disaient sale oui bon je sais pas
oui j'ai et françoise qui me l'a dit je
suis moi on peut quoi où on ne peut pas
lui donner 30 personnes n'y êtes vous
pour décider bon ben j'y vais il va
falloir lui explique mais non écoute je
peux très bien y aller moi m'a renseigné
à te dire exactement
mais pourquoi toi qu'est-ce qui se passe
il semble qu olivier soit très gentiment
vous éviter de rencontrer françois ans
c'est tout simple
juste un frère les portants l'avoir
aperçu sa fenêtre l'autre soir chez elle
mais ravit toujours là bas maintenant
les chinois pensent que dans ces
conditions il serait peut-être
préférable surtout pour vous non pas
tout c'est complètement ridicule
pourquoi toutes ces histoires vous allez
la rencontre est forcément françois un
moment ou un autre
et puis je suis pas en sucre peut tout à
fait y diotte primaire ce serait plus
convenable que ce souhaite livier givet
tu discutes pas l'échec pourquoi tu me
l'envoie alors comment il était accro au
plus tôt et david gay parce que moi je
vais pas me laisser emmerder
je suis content de vous revoir a lancé
françois sera peut-être dû faire comme
vous un grand voyage
j'ai pensé en faire un très long très
long
j'ai manqué de courage se rate et indio
c'est que j'ai lu une annonce du mariage
dans le journal moi j'avais espéré des
années j'avais plus rien à espérer
c'est quelqu'un de bien jambes
il est aussi et nous nous on est moche
enfin oui on est moche les perdants
moi évidemment 50 bons et loyaux
services je suis la fir supermaché avis
c'était pas une raison qu'il craint que
les vielles j'étais mariée sans les
tampons discrètement son enlèvement
j'étais mariée
les étiquettes qui comptent
l'appellation contrôlée
madame le bugue si par appellation war
voir madame enchanté vous avoir connu
beaucoup d'affection beaucoup
d'invectivés par deux ils parlent de moi
des fois
jeter et les oliviers je ne sais pas
demandez pour les états unis
ça s'est passé comment ah oui ah oui si
c'était par françoise et qui reste pour
moi une amie quelqu'un que j'estime une
sorte de je dirais pas une soeur mais je
voulais qu'ils dre mon vieux enfin nous
avons acheté l'espoir ensemble il ya
cinq ans 200 millions fifty-fifty mais
depuis bonsoir j'ai pas si c'est de vous
rend fou et les millions par 10 par 50
et je vous couvre à chaque fois vous
avez des parents garantie aulas
l'interrompt ce que je veux je peux
[ __ ] à la porte de chez vous du jour
au lendemain mais c'est ce qu'ils
méritent peu plus même pas de sagesse
lucien et vous savez la sagesse dans le
vin c'est beaucoup si vous voulez dire
que je dois chercher du crédit ailleurs
c'est pas difficile
oui oui d'ailleurs pour aller partout
sur les autres pour des imbéciles avec
aux extensions vous une région
pour ces expériences les banques el
cerro et sans nombre de vue que dans
votre panorama financiers zéro pointé
c'est votre dernière entre le pet je
vais vous donner 25 v vendangeurs on en
a promis d'autres vont la semaine
prochaine après vous connaissez mon camp
de vendargues je peux pas me
compromettre à conserver le vôtre mes
amitiés chez vous
allez
[Musique]
alors ça va finir oui
et ça immo folle qu'est ce qui vous
prend joseph
vous n'êtes plus un gamin il ya un
moment je lui promets sa route
maintenant s'ils continuent gellman aux
gendarmes
et il m'a mordu au cul stores urgent et
là je suis au wei comprend les jeux
lucien et tourner auprès de ma fille
aime chalumeau allez y là je ne sais
combien d'enfants
lui non plus n'a pas le savoir ma fille
m'a dit ça fait trois fois qu'elle le
trouve à pisser sur le chemin de son
travail
trois fois en un mois vous avez parlé si
naturel non c'est pour ça que vous lui
tomber dessus un peu oui et je vois même
salle aux filles tu te lagarde
il ya déjà été pré pautrat j'ai plus
d'une fois le chalumeau je pourrais pas
rien à faire chez moi moi que
comme à l'église
oui
il veut leur tour
[Musique]
mon chien
soit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pas mal
[Musique]
je les feuilles comme ça
je me suis fait accomplir leur âge ni
colle au delà du sucre est bon ça
[Musique]
à
10/06 elle commence et ça continue tout
le long sur ces deux ans là aucun doute
on vient quand ici il faut modifier le
blog vendanges on va éliminer ces deux
rangées sous sol du tout et ça du dessus
et demain matin au lieu de faire le
maire au but militaire tu reviens ici on
est à tous le tromper embêtant le merlot
et est prête à couler la première grosse
pluie on pourrait peut-être attendre 3 4
jours temps de finir au petit tertre
puis ici je suis pas tellement d'accord
parce que je préfère à perdre un tiers
du merlot du petit tertre qui est tout
jeune plutôt que d'iran déclaré renée 15
à 50 ans je n'ai pas trop vite trois
quatre jours voit les gros matches comme
ça même si jérôme à mon sens c'est plus
raisonnable
je crois pas un mot de ce que tu
racontes raconte des histoires d'un
cousin
ben si tu les connais c'est mieux aucune
imagination la croiser minotiers de père
en fils depuis 1688 ces mamies qui
partout sur leurs sacs sur leurs moulins
sur leur camion
je trouve que c'est une histoire plutôt
rigolote non je trouve que sa bande du
tout moi olivier qui est trop olivier
olivier
pirate m'ont dit que j'étais là je
traduis ton texte pour la branche
anglaise
c'est très bon tu verras j'ai changé de
trois petites choses mais qu'est ce que
tu as
j'aide parler je t'écoute et bien c'est
à quel sujet jérôme c'était l'habitude
de parler non entre d'abord voilà j'ai
un copain on a mis même d'ailleurs tu le
connais servait gallargues
ah ouais on a fait du tennis avec lui en
juin le grand là qui a l'air d'un garçon
coiffeur forte pas du tout qui fait dire
à certains qu'une importance bref il ya
un cousin sur lequel il m'a raconté une
histoire bizarre
hubert chauvigny comme les farines quand
tu sais ça t'a jamais vu de farine chez
un pâtissier leye de la farine qui
s'appelle comme ça chez nous alors ton
monsieur chauvigny rien
écoute mon petit olivier je comprends
rien ce que tu me racontes
mais tu as bien raison de ne pas
empoisonner jérôme avec tous ses
radotages tous ces mensonges d'envieux
c'est eux qui veut pas comprendre
maintenant que je sais exactement la
vérité ce que je te demande c'est un
conseil dans la manière d'aborder le
sujet avec mon oncle est la seule
manière d'aborder le sujet c'est de se
taire se taire écoute je suis une
vieille femme
nous sommes tous très heureux ici et je
ne permettrai la personne de s'attaquer
à manger ou non ne m'enflamme et qui
tous parlent de s'attaquer à jérôme mais
bouscarrat personnes dans cette maison
pour m'écouter et comprendre comprendre
ce que je dis
et voilà
vous êtes sûr de tout ça
pourquoi sauriez-vous parce que c'est
exactement la question que je pose mon
copain blessure puis d'ailleurs j'ai
j'ai vérifié je laissais passer toute
une nuit là dessus et les gens de dire
vraiment je sais plus quoi faire
hier j'ai eu envie d'aller trouver
jérôme et où les déballer mais quand
j'ai su qu'il était parti dans l'après
midi pour les jeunes de bouteilles ça
m'a soulagé oui on t'a vu blanche
on sait que la vaisselle est finie et
que ça m'arrive non elle n'écoute jamais
d'ailleurs elle est très faible
vous avez bien fait de venir mon petit
livre et si je filais l'attendant
maryland le 25 juin comme le temps que
ça serait malin vous êtes trop jeunes
trop impulsif les histoires un peu sale
on laisse ça aux gens d'expérience c'est
moi que ça regarde maintenant à les
tâches et d'oublier tout ça et dormir à
beaucoup la suivante pourquoi merci je
travaille pour moi si je réussis bonsoir
blanche blanchet je suis désolé mais je
dois filer mais juste le temps support
est à 25
tous le même moi qui disais que tu
n'écoutes jamais c'est vrai tu arrêtes
pas de mentir bon bah puisque tu as
entendu tu crois que j'ai une chance
jamais été d'accord pour te coucher à me
pose pas la question
rado deux rabats joie dans ça que tu
m'appelles écoute blanche tu m'énerves
tumeur tard je sais plus où j'en suis
ainsi tiens je te verra porter ça chez
mon frère téléphonie pour m'excuser
j'irai de mme albanel
tu peux pas le faire pourrait même pas
sûr major du téléphone je suis tout le
temps occupé ont une fable en comblant
sion cela pour moi ce sera un âge je
t'adore stable au masque aux rabat-joie
anjra doté de même bonheur ça veut dire
la présence de 10h15 à 11h et 12h dans
le temps oui de bonheur c'était tout
matin c'était même plutôt que le matin
ça oui
comment je suis
[Musique]
il faut les prévenir tout de même osé du
met sally gook quoi en plus
[Musique]
et morlaix
bon
[Musique]
où la pauvre
fair nous la lui bouquet sera bon
celui-là on n'est pas venu ici pour
goûter du vin chalumeau vous savez de
quoi vous accuse je le disais bien aussi
qu'on essaie de me porter atteinte
chaque fois qu'un derrière deux filles
pendant l'ère dans ce pays c'est moi
l'auteur et chalumeau
pourquoi qui te regarde et trois mois a
perdu 1,57
écoutez le stade où ils kruth histoire
que tu veux dire jean les pentes
c'est quand ma femme elle a couché des
jumeaux wind petit parisienne qui m'a
pris dans sa voiture en vacances alors
toujours l'air de dire oui
alors j'ai cru moi j'allais produits en
europe et alors là gueuler alors j ai
foutu quelques bugs et puis ça s'est
bien passé on était contents tous deux
mais j'avais pas quitter sa voiture d'un
quart d'heure que j'étais entre deux
grands cas en fin de rencontre les
gammes ou quoi la pente mais trois mois
trois mois donc payer donc vente
enfin de toute manière vous avez vous
passé la nuit qui précède ma fille non
plus été fait par un montant de monsieur
l'espagne dans les témoins et surnom de
chalumeau s'appelle pouyet rémy pouilles
et c'est pas moi qui m'appelle chalumeau
cha les autres moi je m'appelle pomme je
sais où je suis les autres pour qui tu
appelles pas jonquilles ou tabouret ou
mercredi pourquoi qui t'appelle
chalumeau comme par hasard un outil que
sa forme et sa chaîne comme ça le
meurtre parce qu'il ya eu viol et tous
vous désigne non lui me désigne en fait
vous n'avez pas répondu à ma question et
vous remémore les autres parce que ça
aussi c'est ainsi que de penser à
normale sup et donc ça suffit comme ça
ça suffit
enfin allez vous oui ou non répondre à
la question vous avez vous passé la nuit
dernière
chez moi je mange de la soupe ici qu'à
les jeunes peuvent le dire vers les 9
heures et puis j'ai rentré chez moi un
petit coup de télé ordi minutes pour
m'endormir
vous avez vu dans quoi ils invitent ils
ont pas 3 cuillères mais la télé et au
lit jusqu'au matin ici même c'était
votre soirée qui m'intéresse je sais
votre matinée la m alors la puce arm que
tout le et a7 je viens d'avoir le
lieutenant par radio oui alors on n'y
est pas du tout bon
d'après le premier examen du médecin
légiste il n'y a pas eu viol ah les
blessures à la tête sont postérieurs au
décès ne l'ont donc pas provoqué il ya
eu transport du corps
la mort remonte à une douzaine d'heures
ça change tout oui ça change tout vrai
mais ça reste de notre compétence
compétents inquiéter un brave père de
famille et le menacer sans preuves
compétents de beaucoup youri je m'en
occupe
alors là où la démo crette parce que
ceux qui restent aussi de notre
compétence
c'est le procès verbal insultes
l'agent de la force publique ariane a
insulté moi ah pardon témoins il vous a
traité de couillon grand couillon même
parfaitement couillon et tu te régales à
le répéter à hypocrite déjà au
catéchisme monsieur le gendarme
il était comme ça se joue au christ
[Musique]
nous ne sommes pas plus avons aussi pas
très réjouissant tout ça il faut
comprendre c'est leur fille et tous les
sacrifices qu'ils ont fui ce qu'il
imaginait oui je sais les les études ça
coûte cher ça peut même pas si vous
rouvrez moi je les pousse et moi je ne
suis qu'une voisine
dites moi elle était comment la petite
comment comment vous voulez dire le
physique
non ça je sais j'ai vu les photos plutôt
belle-fille non je dirais sérieuse
sérieux problèmes question que je ne m'y
attendais pas sérieuse mais mon pauvre
monsieur vous croyez que leur
régularisation faire la ville devrait
d'ailleurs
lisez l'article c'est écrit dedans et
par le médecin légiste
une jeune si je suis mais ya pas deux
mais vierge à 26 ans je vous souhaite la
même chose monsieur et madame est à
votre avis la photo dans le journal
ressemblante
ces mots clés de la photojournaliste
hausse à allah et riante elles mêmes à
billets comme le jour où elle est allée
chercher son fiancé à la gare de
libourne la même robe
le même coiffure bah si c'est bien ce
que vous dites on le reconnaîtra
facilement
je remercie madame ya pas de poids à
votre service messieurs
oui je le reconnais c'est lionel
monaco n'est si brutaux mais vous
confirmer ce que nous allions domicile
de la victime venait attendre son fiancé
non lui attendre 1622 vingt deux ans
pourquoi je sais rien excusez moi j'ai
un train
[Applaudissements]
et peut-être remarqué avec le jeune
homme allait arriver un jour
non c'est jérôme lebouc
en 1603
elle pense qu'à lui vous connaissez j'ai
même voté contre les problèmes
/ je me connais
11e fortune dans des pays politiquement
on peut pas vous est formel il n'était
pas dans la micheline formel c'est moi
qui ai ramassé livré à l'adresse pas
tous ensemble jérôme leduc m'bizi
château le bugue vous demanderais mais
pour ce qui du jeune homme dans vos âges
ça devient plus marrant ça non pas du
tout dans les faits trois minutes 10
secondes avant l'arrivée du 7500
étudiants étaient là vous avez remarqué
mais vous la connaissiez pas donc elle
avait quelque chose de remarquable quoi
la gueule si vous voulez savoir ce qu'il
avait dit à sa d'abord dans la gueule à
quelle gueule est plus fort que l'autre
quelle outre une autre j'en sais pas
plus moi c'est déjà beau non c'est
surtout un peu tardive tâcher d'y mettre
un peu de bonne volonté sinon c'est moi
qui aimais trégueux les ouais ça s'est
passé en trois coups un jeune est
arrivée la première je lui ai même fait
évacuer son vélo première à connaître
elle avait rien de spécial blanc
repliable c'est tout une garce et par
garage lecat rentrer en voiture aussi
bref elle attend donc à côté de moi
l'autre arrive c'est le hasard j'avais
l'oeil sur la jeune je la vois changer
de figure il marcher vers l'autre bonne
femme qui bougeait plus tout pâle
qu'est-ce qu'elles se sont dit à ce
moment-là sacs de lait passe à siffler
la vieille pas tellement d'ailleurs
disons de 35 ans jeudi la vieille voilà
finalement elle sert à becqueter mieux
que la jeune et quand elles sont venues
vers la porte pour attendre de chaque
côté un peu comme vous là c'est la
vieille qui sourit l heure après
quand tout le monde a été sorti plus
personne sur le quai et pas de le bugue
changement de tableau la vieille aile
via les prix 15 en mieux elles sont
sorties la jeune suivait ans marrant
c'est là où sur la passerelle que ça
s'est remis à brailler pour preuve que
je comprenne mais assez pour que
j'entends d'ici et c'était la jeune pas
mal cette mousse et sarlat plus le temps
rien entendu un nom un prénom propre moi
c'est une histoire de fric et de la
bourgeoisie là dedans
on voit pas très bien une femme tuée
vers mussidan transporter un corps ne
déshabille pas c'est plutôt une idée
d'homme même une idée est souvent trop
comme passager pont
dans blague à part
on va passer chez le boucher sur ces
quelque chose pour la petite et trouver
nos quelconque elle doit crever de soi
on n'aura pas de mal à trouver pour la
fin mon château par le bugle justement
le château ça tient sa langue -
d'optimus que vous moi aucune idée une
femme qui aurait eu des raisons de se
livrer à cette scène en scène un public
non je ne vois vraiment pas
à l'occasion sinon vous remets j'ai
faits pouvant table si j'avais pris ce
train il était arrivé comme prévu la
devise vrai je ne peux pas police et
olivier mon neveu il ces messieurs
chercheuse beaucoup de choses à la fois
le vélo le lieu du crime bien sûr et une
femme qui aurait eu une violente dispute
avec yvette en gare de libourne
les femmes ont noté que ça m'aurait
étonné si du premier coup mais à la
réflexion on ne sait jamais non vous
pouvez rester pour la bonne règle
vous n'étiez pas dans la machine de
22h25 vous êtes arrivés par quel train
je ne suis pas descendu à libourne
mais à bordeaux j'avais un rendez vous
urgent avec mon sens piquant de
bouteilles à limoges alors à l'aller
j'ai rater mon train à libourne
j'en ai pris un peu plus tard à bordeaux
ce qui m'a obligé à revenir par le même
chemin pour récupérer ma voiture que
j'avais laissé devant la gare de
bordeaux comment aurais-je pu imaginer
qu'il est allé m'attendre mais on vous
laisse
ne vous étonnez pas de nous voir traîner
sur la propriété déçu
pourquoi tu ne la nie la forme de la
gare ne peut-être que françoise et
comment aurait-elle connu lors de mon
retour on n'avions plus aucune relation
avec elle et pourquoi mauritel attendu
pendant les 100 francs soit en dehors de
tout ça elle penche depuis beaucoup à
moi maintenant a dit mme olivier tu n'as
pas fait de bêtises il veut étoiles
j'étais bien fini tu fous tu fous
malheureux tu peux pas savoir quel prix
les gens vont nous regarder parlé dans
notre dos la police va falloir nous
serrer les coudes olivier et bien nantis
alors qui sait j'écoute mais par les
monts soir
c'est une jeune fille qui n'avait pas
d'ennemis vieil homme ni femme
penchez-vous et dans votre équipe là on
n'avait rien remarqué vie jalouse
d'amour et 20 cm sur rien de cadres
l'âge déjà c'est que la jeune un si
petit et j'en vois pas qui restent sur
la banquette
si vous ne comprenez pour la bagatelle
je manque un jour personne d'entre eux
n'avaient jamais vu mademoiselle il
était dans le monde entier allemagne
italie norvège
j'ai eu ici des japonais et un news élan
c'est que dit nourri logé le smig alors
des trains entiers comme pour les
vacances on tient sa place
bonjour merci la bonne femme
c'est ça la filière c'est ce que vous
regardez là
et pas de nouvelle zélande cela et la
finition est tellement j'en avais le
faire un brin de causette bleus
monsieur un belge journée aulas oui je
viens du château le bugle les amis oui
vous avez trouvé pour l'assassinât non à
ben oui c'est à dire la bonne piste vous
le remplacez épique et oui cas c'est des
pourris alors ça va les remplacer
et on appelle ça les carrats sonne en
sciences une femme une femme qui aura eu
des raisons us à teillé ah oui parce que
le châtaignier hills allure plus
longtemps c'est du bois demande tend à y
voyez-vous hossa se tiennent 12 ans 15
ans n'ont vocation à seulement 4 oui
alors maintenant on va se mettre à
essayer le plastique est ce que vous
voulez plus personne va le chercher le
châtaignier maintenant eh oui monsieur
c'est trop fatiguant
en moyenne au vous allez avoir 5000 kg à
l'hectare alors quand hectares fait le
compte 150 me oui on pouvait ajouter 1 0
alors 150 mis le pied vous rendez compte
si vous connaissez pas du travail ça
brille pas pu oublier les labours à ça
c'est le plus important parce que vous
voyez monsieur ces terres là vous prie
de croire que vouloir remuer vouloir
remuer bien des fois alors la langue
vous voyez comment dirais-je à force ça
c'est le deuxième plein d'air comme
menez de redon et oui c'est une
protection du froid et de tous oui elle
est mariée au pauvre vous ne savez même
pas sur chacun des cent cinquante mille
pieds alors vous figurer que certains
pieds se font l'ouvragé même à bas dit
il trop comment de ça et chaque pied oui
et et entre les pays aussi monsieur rémy
et cherche chaque chaque est empli la
tâche et on surveille on fait le voir et
on soigne pour enfant du pays dont vous
la connaissez tout le monde la connaît
d'ailleurs celle que cherche une qui a
des raisons de faire scandale
c'est peu quand les châteaux
jean par une femme qui à dessein sur la
plupart d'une autre c'est trop dur
faurecia votre foi pour ma femme c'est
pas nous sommes sur le tennis et que ça
vous fait de voir l'été peut-être
question bagel à moineaux et la force de
ma pomme mais tout ça reste entre nous
charmer bon alors la championne de
tennis un petit effort
je finirai par savoir obligatoirement
alors faites moi gagner du temps sinon
c'est moi qui vais vous en faire perdre
je n'avais aucune raison de l'insulté
cette petite mon temps était passé nous
sommes séparés d'un commun accord jérôme
et moi c'est tout il n'a pas été seul
homme de ma vie ne sera pas le dernier
j'espère j'ai été mariée divorcée
vous n'avez rien sur le feu parce que
parce qu'il faudrait l'éteindre
nous allons la gare de libourne et
rendre visite à l'employé qui a assisté
à cette scène fabien alors dit
c'était moi
tous
comment ça tout à non asami la dispute
seulement la dispute
je voulais revoir jérôme mais seuls lui
et moi l'attendre au train était une
occasion formidable communes abc mme
auger pas imaginer une seconde que le
sol à la pomme profite quand j'ai vu le
qui vident pas de jérôme cette fille qui
ricanaient qui le verrait lendemain qui
me chasserait de savez une bonne foi
elle avait tout
jeune belle
telli jantes cultivez vous êtes bonne
joueuse
avec tous tous sauf
là
une pierre
qui vous avez renseigné sur le retour de
monsieur le bugue qui je ne sais plus a
su mon frère son adresse vous plaît le
sien lesponne domaine des samares qui
ôte de bergerac votre frère et un ami de
jérôme le but for men des affaires
ensemble somme il s'agissait d'un voyage
concernant leurs affaires justien était
naturellement cours ce sera tout pour
aujourd'hui
je vous remercie
on a vu votre voiture et on a pensé vous
étiez pas loin on a peut être un petit
quelque chose de ratissage c'est lui qui
l'a trouvée sur le telus neuf voiliers
ou lis avec moi là dedans c'est assez
loin de l'endroit où on a trouvé le
corps ça arrive 4 km 300 exactement au
même endroit il ya des traces de
freinage brutal montrent leur
le bercy
c'est moi qui lui avais offert cette
petite chaîne
ou pas la garder désolé
vous avez une idée
une idée pas vraiment disons que je
commence à entrevoir des possibilités si
le crime a eu lieu sur la route
l'hypothèse qui tourne à la conviction
le transport du corps du lieu du crime à
celui de la découverte d'un pose plus
aucun problème d'évacuation du vélo pas
davantage sur tous ces petits engins
repliable et d'armes du crime la plus
commune une arme qui tue chaque jour et
particulièrement les ricaines vous
pensez à l'automobile
l'horaire est une arme qu'on trouve
entre toutes les mains
celle des jeunes fous des vieux fou et
aussi des faibles femmes
il ya quelqu'un oui et suivez moi je
cherche mon patron vous n'avez pas vu il
est derrière le château avec le mien
mais je n'en voyais cherchait déjà pour
quelqu'un qui l'attend dans le bureau au
jeu attendant le dollar aussi a dit moi
il n'y a pas d'autres voitures que celle
que j'ai vu au garage
et alors ça vous suffit pas
monsieur monsieur le bugue ah non le
simple visiteur a très bien je vous prie
de m'excuser ce n'est pas moi qui viens
ici d'habitude mais le collègue du
secteur est ko et champignons vous êtes
dans la partie l'ignoble
ah non dommage vous aurait demandé votre
avis oui c'est celle que vous préférez
c'est nous qui fabriquons verlyck reut
ers pénevayre l'icom imhof j'aime bien
celle ci et je pense bien bonne teinte
le médaillon juste dans le décolleté la
classe à lannion durée de la bouteille
souffler d'ailleurs c'est inspiré de
vieux modèles qu'ils ont trouvé ici au
château en creusant quelque part je le
but devait se présenter la semaine
dernière pour décider une bonne fois il
le connaît par coeur noter seulement
nous on est en fabrication pour 500
mille bouteilles
ça fait du bruit non vous me dites que
monsieur le buc devait se présenter la
semaine dernière vous ne l'avez donc pas
vu si je suis là elle nous a pas rendu
visite le 17
impossible remplaça case 2015 elle était
sur mon bureau mon fils veut dire qu'il
ne pourra pas vous recevoir aujourd'hui
il reviendra plus tôt vous voir mes
hommages madame raoulx grisolles vers
les crus mais on m'a justement prier
d'insister on doit mettre en fabrication
voyez vous alors il faut que monsieur
votre fille choisissent une bonne fois
pour toutes je disais d'ailleurs à ce
monsieur madame je n'ai plus rien
d'ailleurs nous avons de la visite
ça monsieur bien de l'image où l'on n'a
pas vu monsieur le bugue depuis une
éternité que j'ai téléphoné hier encore
à moi donc à la case comme d'habitude
ah oui mais d'habitude ils mangent pas
de champignons laquelle on aurait dû
vous passez à moi j'ai laissé plein de
messages
alors ça va chauffer ses secrétaires
c'est la troisième fois comme voler
c'est cela vous repasserez dans une
heure il y aura peut-être encore
quelqu'un pour choisir
vous n'aimez pas limoges ont été tus
parce que j'en ai marre moi non si toi
aussi tu membres qui d'autre tout le
monde
olivier je t'en prie tiens toi il ya
quand même une question qui reste à
flotter dans l'air et à laquelle je
n'apporterai qu'une légère correction
où étiez vous monsieur le bugue aux
grands moulins chauvigny commença vêtu
qui te fait parler de ça ça nous fait
route vers la mi mai qu'il avait
interdit de la dir jambes des calomnies
pas lui faire la peau ni tout a été tout
le raconter j'ai réfléchi
le mariage c'est un sacrement et
pourquoi le may not tue pas paru à moi
d'abord j'aimerais que vous vous êtes
donc tous on dirait que rien ne vous
êtes un tout vous est égal mais moi ils
veulent je n'étais pas guéri j'étais
déjà demandé de te tenir et moi je dis
que ça suffit non mais sans blague
tiens toi olivier tétouan jérôme nous
les leburgue vous arranger ça aux petits
oignons moi alors
c'est à cause
peut pas se permettre ce qu'on a
yvette vous la connaissiez depuis
longtemps à l'école après impôts
vraiment je suis parti à bordeaux à
paris pour les études ll est resté ici
dans sa famille on l'avait revu quand
c'est pour des vues pendant 10 ans 15
ans 20 puis là aux dernières vacances on
jour même il m'avait demandé d'aller
chercher des macarons olivier
le bugue qu'est ce que c'est devenu
j'étais à paris j'ai terminé mon droit
mon temps je vais travailler avec mon
oncle bien et vous ben moi vous voyez
toujours ici vous voulez des macarons je
pense comme elle 2 ça fait 10 à 6
bon voire deux joueurs jouent au tennis
et elle arrive une fille qui était là
lui dis félicitations pour la grègue
j'avais pas j'ai eu l'air malin avec mon
droit on a joué jouais très mal nous
avouer qu'elle débute et françoise était
la leur donner quelques conseils si une
très bonne joueuse françoise elle a même
été classée oui je sais j'ai beaucoup
revue est pendant les vacances
j'étais amoureux d'elle et la vente de
sa voix
[Musique]
voilà à côté de du toit rouge là juste à
gauche on voit même la maison
complètement c'est bon
non
oh
[Musique]
avant
mon
[Musique]
et
j'ai fait faire des centaines de
kilomètres dans le département rien que
pour la terre des prétoires
[Musique]
un jour je devais amener au château
contexte de lui montrer des deux vieux
papiers d'archivés moitié français
moitié anglais mon idée c'est etc et
qu'elle accepterait de 21h à tort
d'accord d'accord
je remercie
à noël
je vous présente mon oncle il est lucide
à jamais niva et vacances finies les
élèves tourné à périgueux où elle
remplacera importe d'anglais je voyais
tous les 15 jours quand elle entre chez
ses parents j'ignorais que jérôme
lavrilleux chaque semaine je lis sud
plus tard elle m'avait fait un effet
extraordinaire et sous prétexte une
production délicate j'étais allé le
relancer à périgueux je n'étais pas très
fier de moi j'ai tout appris le jour où
j'allais lui demander sa main
oui
pour couteliers il faut que je dise
quelque chose
parce que tu comprends tu pourrais
devenir amoureux de moi ça gâcherait
tout tué mon frère
peut-être même mieux qu'à frère
d'ailleurs tu seras mon témoin oui je
vais me marier
enfin s'il me demande je dis oui tu dois
vivre avec qui
pourtant c'est quelqu'un que tu aimes
toi aussi beaucoup tu veux pas dire
gironde
je crois que seul m je suis parti aux
états unis trois mois 89e exactement
retour est imparfait cicatrices 1 mais
diable tout va très très bien
puis je veux cheval où je rencontre un
copain que j'avais pas revu depuis des
mois jérôme le but qui vient de lancer
son mariage chez toi c'est pourquoi
comme ça je m'en doutais je crois me
souvenir instant les airs l'annoncent
dans le journal monsieur demandé si ce
n'était pas cette jolie fille que tu
m'avais présenté à pâques au tennis en
chignon d'ailleurs ça changerait quoi
changer si c'est toi qui l'a présenté à
ton moins dur que ben c'est une [ __ ]
ils sont content d'accrocher les view
par les jeunes je connais mon cousin
chauvigny il a eu droit à tous les
espoirs puisque ce qui nous mène à la
chasse chez son père
eh bien au bout de deux mois elle
balancé bernard pour le papa il faut
dire que c'est lui qui après ils ont
compris quand ils ont su qu'elle s'était
renseigné chez le notaire
je crois pas un mot de ce que tu
racontes tout raconte des histoires
imaginé une histoire si tu les connais
c'est mieux aucune imagination je ne
l'écouté plus
je trouve que c'est une histoire plutôt
rigolote dans sa grotte du tout moi
olivier quitteront olivier olivier jeu
n'avait été que son fil conducteur la
clé d'un monde dans lequel je n'existais
que pour l'amener à jérôme groggy
complètement sonné je suis pas un moyen
subtil jeu vous ne trouvez libertis même
pour avoir une explication en envoyant
je lis de tout j'ai pris des précautions
et détours chauvigny farine
j'avais vu de farine chez un pâtissier
et de la farine qui s'appelle comme ça
chez nous alors ton messieurs
et puis si tu aurais été pratiquement
fiancée au vieux souvenirs à bas après
avoir ma nouvelle fils qu'est ce que tu
hostile moi j'ai été fier oui je vois
comme ici en somme sauf qu ici j'aurais
manoeuvre elle ne s'en prive lattois
mais enfin olivier tu te rends compte de
ce que tu dis et tu les crois toi
comment vouloir même en tout cas c'est
ce que raconte sage
et sale type
mais en temps au lit vielles qu'est ce
que tu veux que je fasse moi mais
comment vous dire je me défende contre
ça j'étais sûr que c'était pas vrai un
coup d' il est chez comment les avoir le
nez dedans oui qu'est ce que tu fais
demain gironde doit-elle l usine de
bouteilles en ont pensé que je les
invite à déjeuner qui vit tu es bien je
veux ni hervé ils font des excuses
tiens c'est bien toi lâche ce téléphone
effrayant tout noir piges je vais venir
ça m'a rien épargné
pourquoi imposant d'avoir parlé votre
oncle immédiatement ils voulaient ils
étaient là qu'il tourna y ait ici et là
et jérôme états unis où elle sa figure
en voyez bien que ça n'allait pas il m'a
vidé balle et son histoire
ah ça manque de petits enfants ici il ya
que les vieux pour savoir combien ça
ment on a pratiquement supplié de ne
rien lui dire et je vais te raconter sa
version c'est à dire la tienne j'ai été
démoli je n'ai pas eu le courage
d'affronter bête si tout ça c'était que
des ragots
je la perdrai à tout jamais mais si
c'était la vérité c'est pour ça qu'ils
nous a joué la comédie du voyage à
l'image pour filer renseignements se
souvient ni pour savoir être le seul à
savoir mais savoir exactement et j'ai su
seulement chauvine et s'est dégagé à
temps lui mais moi les faire-part et est
renvoyé des bancs publics
je ne pouvais plus reculer aucune
solution
s'il ya dans l'étude
on la connaissait vous devriez avoir
honte géante vous êtes 2 auquel profiter
si l'on peut dire la mort de la petite
vous d'abord elle vivante l'héritage de
but vous passer sous le nez elle morte
de rentrer dans l'ordre plus de scandale
à redouter oublie complètement con vous
étiez le seul à connaître l'heure du
retour de votre oncle c'est françoise
alors françoise si moi qui l'ait prévenu
non à moi eh bien oui c'est olivier est
alors n'allez pas vous mettre à hurler
chez moi non vous aurez l'obligeance de
remarquer madame que ce n'est pas moi
qui hurle mais vous nier tout jusqu'à
l'évidence
premier mensonge il ya 48 ans était
votre frère qui vous avaient donné
l'heure du retour de votre amant
aujourd'hui c'est bien olivier le bugue
deuxième mensonge
à vous entendre rupture dans le charme
au revoir et merci témoignages armand
les nus il vous a entendu ça n'avait pas
l'air d'aller tout seul à votre habitude
vous oubliez comme à la gare c'est ça
votre rupture de cham
j'aurais dû pleurer de joie vous auriez
dû dire la vérité la vérité cavale après
moi tous les jours matin et soir
et vous dire ce qui s'est passé brrr
entrée de la gare une série vaincu par
une petite aventurière de province que
vous attendez sur la route et bois votre
dernière chance
ce n'est pas par les ingérences 7
interrompre une bonne fois pour toutes
sa conversation avec yvette ensuite avec
de la patience il vous reviendra tout ou
tard donc un coup de volant qui règle la
perf' cela car oui vous avez dit je
m'occupe de tout je travaille pour moi
à 10h30 on me voyait encore en gare de
libourne à 11 heures j'étais ici j'étais
moins deux mois au tête à son service un
pèsera pas nouveau comme témoignage
aussi étaient là ils attendaient et
roulera qu'il est venu en train
malgré mon coup de téléphone place ça
n'intéresse pas ces messieurs c'est moi
que ça intéresse des saint thomas bon
alors moi je donne des preuves
elle pleurait tu pleurais dit par nous
au moins on ne pousse à bout moi je
prouve mais j'ai de la mémoire moi même
votre conversation et maristes si nous
voilà dans le même sac
mon pauvre lui je la vente ou non vous
vous rendez compte que vous m'offrez là
une solution de complément bigrement
intéressante si vous n'avez pas pu faire
entre 10h30 et 11h c'est à dire
transporté le corps maquiller le crime
votre frère a pu le terminer après vous
avoir quitté c'est peut-être ça le même
sac
cassant ce off puis croyait ce que vous
voulez
messieurs bonsoir c'est aujourd'hui nous
servir sur cire tel instant que c'est
pas tous les jours aussi terne
comment se porte le mieux
oui une pâte à lola sans beurre est
censé commis hier à un peu mieux et
goûter si c'est possible et un an deux
yachts nature c'est pendant la bouffe
avec vous alors une nouille aussi mais
avec du jus de viande est un peu de
beurre un peu de froid peut-être et voit
chez faf afin d'avoir un jeune alors
pour moi la terrine l'andouillette
serait bien très bien
bon alors terrines et andouillettes et
le civet de lièvre c'est du yougoslave
hongrois n'ont nort-sur-erdre vous voyez
ce que je peux avoir mon eau tiède tout
de suite il est monsieur comme boisson
[Musique]
ben le but
pourquoi pas vous avez là un choix à
bordeaux appellation contrôlée ce front
et bien et puis le château le bug
évidemment le château c'est autre chose
38 francs elle dit ça fait une
différence
tu comprends du simple au double puisque
jeudi le double plus du double 120% moi
pauvre monsieur j'ai dû rouge de ces à
la france est pas si mauvais une
question de moyens et de goût va
l'humain et le go 16 go
le château je comprends mais le rouge
comme vous dites et les bordeaux
appellation contrôlée la différence vous
l'avez des appellations contrôlées
il a la bonne origine déjà non plus une
garantie
il ne tient pas de saint-émile omettre
castillon à 8 kilomètres d'ici c'est pas
du saint-émilion mais ça y ressemble au
moins finie en tout cas c'est bien
meilleur que le grand coup ce que vous
venez à paris le plus cher on importe au
sort de primates enfin pour babur
surtout qu'il faut voir le prix de
revient
les prêts de cultures ont augmenté d'au
moins un tiers depuis 18 mois et le prix
de la terre à bientôt triple triple un
domaine comme le bugue mauvaise revendre
c'est pas 500 millions il ya deux ans
aujourd'hui vous l'auriez pas pour le
triple sept mois le bugue
c'est plus important c'est un premier
grand cru mais le spawn ne vous
connaissez lucien ce je le connais mais
lui c'est pas la même chose quand même
20 hectares au prix que vous indiquez
c'est important
oui ça à 100 millions à peu près au
cours deux jours mais attention à pas
toutes à louis aragon
il paraît que j'ai rompu le bugue
justement à presque toutes les parts
dans la sphère à force de racheter les
espérances de lesponne année sur année
enfin ça c'est des affaires privées moi
je m'en mêle pas la folie des grandeurs
folie folie c'est à vous me donnez un
château de buc 66 et il vous fait
marcher mais pas la petite à fin mai
monsieur enfers de 13
vous avez pigé donc l espagne vous allez
vous occuper un peu sérieusement du
frère lasserre ont ces jalousies
mëme si la rupture avec les le bugue
rupture définitive ça peut lui coûter
groupe
c'est la vie on se casse de faire le
méchant non après pour les bagnoles vous
ne m'avez pas donné le résultat des
examens
ah oui j'ai vu le gâteau au chocolat aux
gens pour moi madame je vois pas
pourquoi le ciel et spawn ne pourrait
pas s'en tirer aussi bien beau jeu
certainement pas c'est d'abord une
question de capacité personnelle
oui ensuite deux surfaces
parce que si vous produisez moins de
cent mille bouteilles par an nous on a
du mal à vous faire connaître en france
et hors du territoire pas question et de
capitaux aussi parce que le
vieillissement de nos vins en barriques
nous coûte environ 1% par mois impose
d'évaporation et pour un vieillissement
de nos trois ans 24 à 36 %
non vous savez lucien est un cap
[Musique]
alors elles sont toutes là
vous ne vous souvenez pas comment vous
avait raflé votre voiture je voulais dit
déjà le matin dans mon garage fois la
découverte
steve est là j'ai appris cette chose
affreuse j'ai vu avertir ses parents je
tremblais comme une feuille
incapable de sortir la voiture j'ai même
accroché sur l'olivier au fait avec les
vendangeurs il ya bien une centaine de
personnes qui logent au château qu'il
s'endorme pas toutes à la même heure
surtout parce belle soirée
personne ne vous avez rentrée je suis
passé par derrière à quelle heure 11
heures si je rencontre quelqu'un fallait
bien que je sois un voyageur plausible
de la micheline de 10h25
ouais
vous pouvez passer pour quelqu'un
d'assez violent au fond qui moins
violent une histoire de chasse il ya
deux ans vous avez blesser un certain
monsieur brochon qui vous prenait à
perdre vous avez tiré ensemble je lui
maintiens dessus d'un coup de crosse et
qui vous a raconté cette histoire
l'intéressé lui-même sa matin au
téléphone
la voiture de lucien lesponne la2
bourgnon sur l'ailé avant droite celle
de françoise joly éraflures toujours du
côté droit
quant à celle d'olivier le bugue du
pareil au même
autre neveu est hors de cause
si c'est vous qui avait raflé sa voiture
bien sûr c'est moi je voulais dix ans de
toute façon ilan halimi très sérieux il
a passé toute la soirée avec les
vendangeurs c'est l'espagne jusqu'à une
heure du matin
quant à votre voiture mais on en a déjà
parlé
alors le neveu dit vrai ils sont un peu
chamboulé soir là à chaque fois que le
sporting a oui au départ d'olivier
lespaul n'était pas encore rentré
n'apprennent défi il est rentré à 2
heures du matin ce qu'on a c'est le fond
de teint ou le chocolat d'hier soir tout
cas le but gaufres un vin de fin de
vendanges de ré et c'est ça vous fera
peut-être du bien en tout cas j'en ai
profité pour lancer les invitations et
tonton jérôme a accepté d'inviter tout
son petit monde y compris françoise et
lucien lesponne gentiment
autrefois c'était une fête un pauvre
félix on n'est pas toujours maître chez
soi
enfin je bayisa mon grand fils
d'autres amis viendront ce soir j'espère
qu'ils viendront les gens sont si
étrange c'est la spécialité du pays avec
nos vins bien sûr je vous demande pardon
mais avec quoi ce blanc d'oeuf et
amendes
il fallait beaucoup de poules autrefois
dans les vignobles pour produire les
oeufs avec lesquels ont collé le vin et
le reste est toujours de ces oeufs alors
on a inventé le macaron est une des
meilleures maisons d'ailleurs qu'est ce
que j'ai dit je pense que tout le monde
et y est a fait le rapprochement avec la
petite mussidan il va bien falloir qu'on
en parle d'une bonne foi et si possible
une bonne dernière fois vous avez une
idée non 4 2
3 et 4 vous avez tué yvette par dépit
amoureux ou par intérêts sordides
quand il n'ya pas de femmes il n'y a pas
d'enfant quand il n'y a pas d'enfant
c'est les neveux qui hérite mais
première idée abandonnée entre 10 heures
et demie du soir une heure du matin vous
étiez à noyer votre chagrin devant
trente témoins restent trois personnes
qui ont chacune mobile et patras d'alibi
à l'heure du crime quoi témoignage de
votre domestique
on lui ferait même pas prêté serment
acide ne vous en tirerez pas parler
sous-entendez quant à vous en libye 0
étrange retour d'un gallopin qui a fait
une mûre entre 10h30 11h nous avons donc
une jeune fille sur une route et
peut-être aussi au volant d'une voiture
un homme violent et désespérés ou bien
une femme violentée hull série qui se
venge
au nord un autre sous le coup d'une
révélation affreuse sa soeur vient
d'avoir une scène qui pourrait lui faire
perdre son domaine et oui le même sac
ça peut vouloir dire que rien avec les
lesponne aux red bull toujours vers
saint-émilion vous vous disposez d'une
voiture qui vous permet de la rejoindre
aucune impossibilité et la jeune fille
entre dans le faisceau des phares à dieu
quelle voiture qui va lâchement provoqué
l'accident qu'on pourra attribuer à
quelques chauffard
évidemment un calcul dernière le
transport du corps à plusieurs
kilomètres du lieu du crime
on aurait pu tout aussi bien déposer à
quelques dizaines de mètres
mais non il a été déposée sur les
vignobles le but et qui plus est dans la
parcelle qui devait être vendangé le
plus tardivement
je pense que vous étiez au courant du
plan de vendanges
oui comme tout le monde ici un vraiment
parfait et la modification de ce plan
vous le connaissez aussi naturellement
un an on a décidé au tout dernier moment
avec monsieur jérôme le matin même vous
comprenez ce que ça signifie pour rien
au monde jérôme l'abus nous renvoyer ces
vendangeurs sur la parcelle on ne
pouvait manquer de découvrir le corps
immédiatement tandis que vous ignorant
cette modification ménardeau
quand vous je me demande ce que je vais
faire je vous laisse aller au bénéfice
du doute
je t'en prie messieurs dames bonsoir
monsieur
oui vous vous pensez que tout ça sera
étalée dans la presse
une certaine discrétion petit de sa wii
mais je vais avoir l'air de quoi moi
jol monsieur ménard de encore mal au
coeur alors nous promenade
[Musique]
et
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
il
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]